as Russia's invasion of Ukraine drags on
becoming even more brutal Vladimir Putin
is looking really isolated on the world
stage but he does have one very powerful
friend Xi Jinping his Chinese
counterpart China has avoided any
criticism of Russia so far in this war
and it's even been providing quite
significant diplomatic backing now this
speculation that it could go further
even providing Military Support to
Russia I wanted to find out more about
this so I spoke to Bonnie Glaser she's
one of America's foremost experts on
Chinese foreign policy and she's based
at the German martial Fund in Washington
DC I started by asking her how important
a moment is this for China in its
relations not just with Russia but with
the West
I think this is a very pivotal moment
for China in its foreign policy
and uh particularly for Xi Jinping who
has been in office for 10 years but I
think has not yet faced the kind of
choices that he faces today China has in
the past tried to position itself
between Russia and the United States and
uh increasingly Siegen ping views Putin
and Moscow is a very important strategic
partner but China has always valued its
relationship with the United States and
try to avoid taking any action that
would really severely damage its ties
with the United States but I think that
Xi Jinping believes that the United
States is now implacably hostile toward
China he saw this start under the
Republicans in the Trump Administration
and now continue under the Biden
Administration and I think he has
therefore attached more value to Russia
and has tilted quite side of late
decisively towards uh toward Russia in
this uh this war in Ukraine
now what do we just just for a moment to
go into some of the background because
you remember you mentioned how China has
been strengthening or Xi Jinping has
been strengthening his relationship with
Vladimir Putin just before the war
Vladimir Putin was in Beijing he met Xi
Jinping and the two of them issued a
really major statement on uh China
Russia relations can you tell us like
what was in this statement and how
important was it
well the statement uh was a very
comprehensive account of the various
things that the uh the Chinese and the
Russians agree on and particularly uh
presidents Putin and Xi Jinping uh it
started out by saying that their two
countries have more successful
democracies than the West uh their
government systems are superior
and really listed many of the things
that they uh that they criticize that
the that the West is doing like the
August the Australia uh us UK
arrangement to deliver nuclear
submarines uh the strategies of of the
United States very much criticized but
what was really most notable to me was
uh their agreement on opposing NATO
expansionism and China's support for
Russia's proposals to put in place new
security Arrangements in Europe these
are new positions for China so the
Chinese have always opposed U.S
alliances as Cold War relics but they
have mostly focused on the alliances
that are really to the east of China
particularly Japan and Korea sometimes
of course Australia but they don't
usually emphasize NATO
um in addition uh the two leaders
celebrated what they called this no
limits partnership and that actually is
not a new term it had been introduced in
2018 by Chinese foreign minister Wang Yi
but it was the first time that it was
included in a joint statement between
Russia and China
so that's what you would see as fashee
the value of this relationship than with
Russia it's very much in antagonism then
to the United States and to its
alliances
yes I think that the intensifying
competition and antagonism between the
United States and China
has led to a privileging of Russia's
position in China's foreign policy it
has made Russia more important for uh Xi
Jinping the those two leaders share the
analysis of of the world I think and and
the vision
that the United States should play a
less important role in the international
order uh they oppose U.S hegemony and
they would like of course the world and
the International System to be more
favorable to autocracies like themselves
and so this is an agenda that Russia and
and China have been pushing already at
the United Nations for example as they
have worked on things like uh cyber
Norms
new definitions of Human Rights treaties
for outer space that would protect their
their interests so this partnership has
grown over time but in the last few
years as the U.S China relationship has
become more contentious it has become
even closer that trend has just
accelerated
and yet you certainly couldn't call this
a partnership of equals could you uh
China is massively more powerful than
Russia particularly in economic terms
right
absolutely true that it's not an equal
partnership and uh that China is a much
stronger player in terms of its overall
GDP I believe that to win the war in
Ukraine started Russia was the 11th
largest economy in the world it's
probably dropped since then and will
drop further and China is of course at
number two uh and China's capabilities
and areas of technology and Innovation I
think um outstrip Russia's as well but
it's important to note that China has
not treated Russia as a junior partner
and particularly Xi Jinping has given
Vladimir Putin the respect that he
craves so when those two men get
together I don't think that Putin is
made to feel like the junior partner
another point is that the two countries
don't agree on everything so where they
have different perspectives such as
maybe the South China Sea or or the
Arctic or maybe even Central Asia where
so far China has had the upper hand in
the economic area but Russia has been
more important in the security realm but
in all of those issues they have
essentially compartmentalized these
areas of potential difference and not
permitted them to spill over into areas
where they want to work together and
where they share these common interests
and that's unusual for two countries to
be able to do and yet they have been
very effective at doing that
now of course Russia has initiated this
war just before we talk about China's
position on this there's been a lot of
speculation about Putin kind of gave Xi
Jinping a heads up when they met that
time in Beijing at in early April what's
your best guess on that
well I think that when the
tutors met on February 4th just before
the Olympics uh Vladimir Putin himself
probably did not have in mind a massive
major military operation by Russia in
Ukraine so he certainly may have told uh
Xi Jinping that he had some intention to
use uh military forces he may have
outlined the possibility of a very short
incursion or you may not have provided
details so some people posit that uh
Siegen pain was was snookered or or
played
um I myself don't think that Xi Jinping
felt that he was in any way lied to or
misled because I think Putin himself at
that moment did not know exactly what he
was going to do now whether uh Vladimir
Putin then kept Xi Jinping informed as
he can change his mind and as the uh
this notion of the major military uh
operation is that decision was made that
I don't know uh but I think that Xi
Jinping likely felt somewhat sympathetic
with Russia's position because after all
the Chinese truly believe that it is
NATO expansion expansionism the five
waves of NATO expansion as they say uh
in their in their statements that is
really responsible for uh for this war
they do not blame Russia
so now the war is underway and it's of
course taken on this this huge scale and
it's been very very destabilizing in the
world politically but also economically
the markets have been in turmoil um
commodity prices are soaring that's not
good for the Chinese economy
how happy or unhappy do you think Xi
Jinping will be by the simple facts of
what are happening now
I think China is very uncomfortable uh
with the current situation in part
because it has aligned itself of course
so close so closely with Moscow uh and
the Russians are killing large numbers
of Civilian uh this is a very bad look
uh for China which has has just uh in
the last stairs so vetoed the
international uh court of justice order
uh to Moscow to end the war and and yet
again China sided with Russia even as it
is killing civilians I I do not think
this is a comfortable position for China
to be in uh but it you highlight another
important aspect and that is the
instability of the global economy and
when CJ and pink spoke with Chancellor
Schultz and uh French president macron
he also emphasized concerns about the
global economy uh China is as you know
very connected to the global economy
does not want to see instability in in
markets
um and and surely would like to see an
end to this war but I would emphasize
that it wants an end to this war in
which uh um Moscow is not in feebled
Russia is not you know severely weakened
as a as a country and and so I think
that uh that is important uh for for
China and and China has
um indicated that it might in some way
be willing to help to bring in into this
war but the reality is is it has not
stepped up
um it has done very little uh to help
bring uh and and uh to this War uh but
of course as time goes on um if this war
continues to rage uh Chinese interests
will be increasingly I think damaged and
Xi Jinping himself will come under uh
criticism not only abroad but
potentially at home Siegen ping faces a
very important party Congress in the
fall where he is slated to get a third
five-year term in office and I am sure
he does not want to put that at risk
so could you just encapsulate the degree
to which China really is supporting uh
Russia because of course we've seen it
abstain that the United Nations in the
security Council so in the general
assembly uh you mentioned that the veto
on that other point how far has it
leaned towards supporting Russia really
openly
well I think that in the area of uh
rhetoric a declaratory policy that China
has cited uh quite clearly with Russia
not of course 100 percent uh China has
an interest in the U.N Charter as it
says and defending its own or upholding
its own long-standing position of
protecting territorial integrity and
sovereignty China does view Ukraine as
an independent sovereign country but
China has has not
condemned the use of force which it has
in every other use of force that has
been made certainly by the United States
but also Russia if we go back to the
Russian and U.S airstrikes in Syria a
few years ago China condemned the use of
force but it has not done so in this war
and uh it repeatedly the Chinese talk
about Russia's legitimate security
concerns that should be protected so
surely China is trying to straddle to
balance um its interests but it really
has cited significantly uh with Moscow
but when it comes to actions that's
where we are I think
um still an uncertain ground and maybe
in early stages uh the Biden
Administration has suggested that China
may have already told Russia that it
would provide some support for its
military but we don't know in fact
whether that's the case both Moscow and
Beijing have denied that I don't think
we've seen any evidence that China has
tried to provide uh Munitions or
surface-to-air missiles or logistical
support or intelligence which is what
has been reported in the Press we've
seen no evidence yet of Chinese uh
violation of the sanctions which is
another question and perhaps Russia has
made some ass of China or perhaps China
is looking for ways to help China could
help Russia's economy without directly
violating the sanctions and so that's
another area that I think that people
are watching very very closely but it's
it is early days
um and we we know that China's
commercial banks for example are not
going to uh violate the sanctions
because that would put at risk their own
access to the International Financial
system so those aren't the kinds of
things we should be looking for but
maybe smaller Chinese Banks or China
lending parts of its reserves or maybe
the Chinese policy Banks like the
development bank or the ex-in bank could
provide loans directly to Russian
Enterprises and not have to go through
the banks so there are things that China
can do and I think the Biden
Administration is trying to discourage
China from doing anything to help Russia
even if it is uh not in direct violation
of the sanctions and that's where of
course we've heard from Beijing that
they said they will conduct trade
Financial interactions
with with Russia as as as normal
um but words are one thing and then
actions are something else and and so
we'll have to see again what are the
decisions China makes does China want to
be to basically throw in its lot with
Russia
um or does it want to continue to
balance these interests and try to
preserve its relationship not just with
the United States but importantly with
Europe and I think that China should see
Europe as a very important player going
forward because China wants to continue
to have the trade and economic ties that
it has with Europe and also I think sees
Europe as an important poll in the
International System that may not always
be aligned with the United States so we
have an important EU China Summit coming
up on April 1st and and I think that
that's another development to watch
going forward
now of course we've talked about the the
various areas in which China could
support Russia the military field is
obviously particularly sensitive
um if China did start providing some
kind of Military Support what would that
mean like how big a step would that be
if China went ahead with that
it would be huge
if the ukrainians uncovered for example
a ballistic or cruise missile that has
Chinese markings on it that had been
fired by Russia
and I think that that would really be a
game changer in China's relationship
with Russia if they provided Munitions
that were being used uh to Target uh
things like hospitals
um and and maternity uh Awards uh this
is the kind of thing we've seen reported
that the Russians are targeting
civilians and if the Chinese are
complicit I think that that would just
be enormously consequential in a very
negative way for China's relationship
with the rest of the world
so what are we talking about are we
talking about you know a kind of a huge
new Cold War scenario the the cleaving
of the world into two blocks would we
have to talk about the war on you in
Ukraine as a proxy war between the west
and China
I think that's exactly right I think
increasingly Ukraine would begin to look
like a a proxy war
um and that this cold war that everybody
has been denying could ever come about
not not of course exactly like the U.S
Soviet Cold War but a new version of it
that we would have to say yes that's the
new world we are entering
let's think a little bit in the other
direction what do you think it would
take for China to drop Putin
we've seen Putin taking very very risky
actions we've seen Putin and his forces
targeting civilians
at what point do you think it just gets
all too much uh for the Chinese to
stomach are we talking about if it veers
into the use of a chemical or tactical
nuclear weapons or or is it just more
scenes like we've seen from Mario Paul
for instance
well I think more scenes like what we
have uh seen from uh Mario poll I think
it's not enough uh to change China's uh
stance
however if the Russians were to use
chemical uh biological weapons God
forbid nuclear weapons yes
um I think that that would really cause
the Chinese to reconsider
the downsides of sign of siding so
closely uh with Moscow I think they they
already as I said feel a bit a bit
uncomfortable
but that would I think just be over the
top uh for for China I don't think that
that's something that they would be able
to ignore uh but even without such a
catastrophic developments there is the
possibility of some understanding
between the United States and China and
if Xi Jinping is looking for
um some way to perhaps distance himself
a little bit from Moscow I don't think
he would cut off his relationship
completely but if he sees that it's in
China's interests I think that's what
some people hope is that he will if we
give him uh the opportunity uh to back
away a bit that he will do so I believe
that this is a proposition we probably
should test we have uh responsibility uh
to the people of Ukraine and to the rest
of the world to test the proposition
that China is not willing to continue
down this path of siding with the rep
apprehensible actions that Russia is
taking against Ukraine
I mean what's the the smartest approach
in your view from the U.S standpoint but
also for the Europeans I mean we we've
had particularly the US there's there's
been a bipartisan kind of grow growing
bipartisan consensus that the United
States has to push back very hard
against China that it has to Rally
allies to stand up against China as the
predominant um authoritarian power in
the world
do you see voices becoming louder in
saying well actually the West really has
to try to hold or reach out to China to
get it on site against Russia and this
being a kind of a flip of a debate that
was happening previously about whether
the West had to reach out to Russia to
peel it away from China
the right strategy is at this point to
peel China away but perhaps to paint for
Beijing the two different Pathways that
they face
uh one of course is uh that Xi Jinping
decides that he has cited too closely
with Moscow that he backs away a bit
that um perhaps really does take a
neutral stance agrees to abide by all of
the sanctions
um even if China is unwilling to play a
role in encouraging Putin to back off
that it stops playing an unhelpful role
and begins to signal that it is time to
bring an end to the war
um the other pathway for China of course
is is a negative one and and it is one
in which the United States and Europe
must clearly signal to China that if it
helps Russia uh in its um uh in its in
its military efforts or if it aids the
Russian economy that it will face uh
punitive measures from the United States
and Europe and let's be clear that if
China is not compliant with the
sanctions those measures should include
secondary sanctions on China
and this is a conversation that the US
and Europe I hope are already having and
I hope that we can be on the same page
because we all know that imposing
sanctions on China is very different
than imposing sanctions on Russia
if China doesn't tip so far in that
direction
um you mentioned earlier that China's
showed no signs so far of attempting to
mediate but is it to you conceivable
that some kind of mediation role could
emerge for China
particularly given that it is one of the
few countries that might have some
influence on Russia's Behavior
I do not think that we should support
China playing the role as mediator
because China's not an uh
are disinterested uh
um actor it is not neutral
it has very strong interests I believe
in having Russia not be weakened by this
war and seeing an outcome that protects
Russia's vital interest
so I do not think that China
should be in a position of playing the
role of mediator that said if Xi Jinping
has a private conversation with Putin um
and wants to encourage him to
um
agree to more substantive negotiations
and to actually reach a ceasefire um and
and and some negotiated outcome I'm sure
everybody would welcome that but I just
don't think that China is a neutral
Observer I do not think it should be
playing the role of of mediator and
there are other countries that have
stepped up such as Israel who probably
um are far better suited and far better
equipped to play this kind of role
just a final question in your expertise
you focus a lot on Taiwan over the years
um there's been a lot of talk of
comparisons between this situation and
and China's desire to to take control of
Taiwan a lot of talk about the
differences as well um between the
scenarios
um what lessons do you feel China will
be learning as this crisis plays out
with a view to its aspirations on Taiwan
we know that China studies previous Wars
draws lessons from them uh the Chinese
military certainly studied the the Gulf
War and applied some of those Lessons
Learned to its own modernization and
planning in this case uh the war in
Ukraine probably does carry some lessons
for China but the war is not over yet so
the we cannot be clear about what
lessons that it will learn but at least
from what we have seen so far I think we
should expect that China will draw uh
some lessons from the strength of the
Ukrainian resistance and recognize that
even a country with a very strong
conventional military Advantage such as
Russia has over Ukraine does not mean
that Victory can be easily secured and
of course the other side of that coin is
that Taiwan should learn the lesson
itself that it needs to prepare a
civilian resistance because Taiwan does
not have a territorial Defense Force
like Ukraine has and Taiwan is beginning
to bolster its reserves but it really
has not developed a a civilian Defense
Force so uh that's interactive the
lessons that Taiwan and China themselves
might might draw I think that China will
also draw some lessons from the unity of
the United States and Europe and and
Japan South Korea so many countries
around the world that have been willing
to uh to put sanctions on on Russia
again China is is a different case than
Russia and there may not be as much uh
willingness to impose sanctions on on
China but but China's expectation that
these alliances of the United States are
fraying
um and that the the East is rising the
West is declining um and they I think
that these are wrong analytic judgments
that China has made so I hope that they
uh as part of these lessons will will
rethink uh the trends in the in the
global of global balance of power and
their own power will it to other
countries one lesson I think China will
not draw
um some people have said that because
the United States did not come to
Ukraine's help militarily that it would
therefore not come to taiwan's Aid uh
militarily and and this is
disinformation that Beijing actually is
telling Taiwan the United States is
going to abandon you I I don't think
that China will draw that lesson at all
the Chinese understand
um that Ukraine is very different uh
than uh than Taiwan is and let's be
clear that President Biden even before
the conflict started made it made it
clear that the United States was not
going to enter this this war militarily
if Russia invaded But we still uh
continue to have a policy of strategic
ambiguity uh which increasingly I think
is a likelihood that the United States
would intervene although we do not give
Taiwan an ironclad commitment that we
would defend it but I think given the uh
the growing competition uh between the
United States and China that it is um
almost
um inevitable that the United States
would come to taiwan's defense so I
think that China does have to factor
that in but they will watch this
military operation and uh the future of
U.S alliances and see how uh the U.S and
its allies are willing to incur some
costs themselves and maybe they would do
the same if uh China were to attack
Taiwan so they will study this for some
time to come I do not believe that
Beijing is um has already made a
decision that it must use Force against
Taiwan
um I think that they are quite confident
in their large toolkit for coercive
actions against Taiwan economic
diplomatic militarily they know that
they can deter Taiwan from going
independent reunification is a more
long-term goal for China
Bonnie Glazer fascinating a lot to think
about there thank you so much for your
time today thank you